traveling to Prague by train student
Aidan Gibson from Edinburgh has embarked
on an intricate venture across Europe
he's fascinated by Prague's stunning old
town and of course no visit to the Czech
capital is complete without seeing the
famous 14th century Charles Bridge
Aven says some things remind him of his
native Edinburgh
have a lot of street music and artists a
lot of events on but I think Prague is
it's very different I think actually
nicer than I expected I think yeah the
buildings are really amazing when you
see it with your own eyes
yeah so very I think it's worth to come
because it's nicer in person
[Music]
his internal ticket has been paid for by
the European Union after Eden proposed a
travel route and successfully answered a
Europe quiz a Giri picked him along with
fourteen thousand nine hundred and
ninety-nine other lucky eighteen year
olds from the EU to embark on this
unique trip through Europe a journey
with a mission will be ambassadors of
this program and hopefully it's gonna
run for many years because I think it's
good it's positive change and I'll be
sharing my experiences through social
media and probably not giving talks but
I could also do that if I wanted to and
yeah that's pretty much it I will be an
ambassador yeah the free interval
program is the idea of Martin Speer and
Vincent Amano hare who lobbied Brussels
to introduce the travel program for
young Europeans the intricate itself has
been around since 1972 Martin Speer and
Vincent Amano hare believe free travel
across the continent can help youngsters
overcome stereotypes about the European
neighbors that's what the two of them
experienced when they themselves went on
an interval adventure years ago
[Music]
we experienced great hospitality we were
invited to people's homes for dinner in
cities we were visiting at the time some
would even let others know we were
coming to their city those were key
moments for us all those new connections
those new friendships that we struck up
to us that really felt like Europe we
got a whole new perspective on Europe
and truly understand that Europe is not
so much about its laws of politics but
about the diversity of its people many
of the lucky 15,000 teams are sharing
their travel experiences on social media
describing their encounters with fellow
Europeans but does this actually help
forge a sense of European identity
critics point out that it does little
good if all these young travelers do is
party the night away
[Music]
Aiden Gibson for his part has vowed to
spend time exploring the history of the
countries he visits in products museum
of communism Aiden learns about the
emergence of the former Czechoslovakia
and its ties to the Soviet Union he's
well aware that after brexit are the
British youngsters like him will no
longer have an opportunity to win a free
internal ticket he is deeply
disappointed with the outcome of the
referendum I think a lot of people voted
blindly initially and they didn't really
know what they were voting about they
were kind of following government
propaganda like communism actually and
then it's time for a cold beer this is
after all the home country of the peers
now after two days in Prague it's time
for Eden Gibson to move on intro could
be described as a kind of speed-dating
with Europe you've barely gotten to know
a place and you're confronted with
another stranger and quite often you
travel alone which is just when 18 year
old Aidan once you can really meet so
many other solo travelers and actually
maybe make some good friends over the
way and
can actually have a very good time
traveling solo so I highly recommend it
the next stops for Aiden are Vienna
Budapest and Ljubljana he'll visit four
European countries in two weeks and take
lots of fresh impressions home to
Emperor